that PlayStation experience on the
weekend sony announced that starting
december eight you can get a 12 month
subscription to their PlayStation now
service for one hundred dollars
PlayStation now enables access to a
library of PlayStation 3 games which can
then be streamed to any playstation
console and select smart TVs and blu-ray
players Sony noted on their blog that
the new all you can play deal represents
a fifty-five percent saving compared to
those who opt ur in you every month sony
has said this is a limited-time offer
and current PlayStation now members are
able to buy the new package to extend
their one or stream lots subscriptions
sony also announced that nine new warner
brothers games have been added to the
playstation now library including Mortal
Kombat Korea's single-player campaign
batman arkham asylum batman arkham
origins and a number of Lego titles
there are now more than 250 games
available on the service and new games
are added each month Microsoft does not
currently offer a similar streaming
service but they do offer their recently
introduced backwards compatibility for
Xbox 360 titles on the Xbox one for free
let me know in the comments if you think
PlayStation now is worth the money and
for everything else that matters in
gaming it keep it tuned to game [ __ ]